just doing his impression of every
terrible family member you've ever had
ever
hey can I borrow some money guys yeah
we're rolling alternative title of nice
not too deep it's been a long day guys
Mitchell's on French time I'm on a
fridge thing that's my free choice I
guess like a bad impression isolating
our entire French audience and so he has
a serious case of the jet lag happening
over his body right now so he is clearly
delirious is bonkers in the brain that
is you burping like what a French way to
burp along in control yeah you burp like
Gerard Depardieu you're welcome we're
back it's myself grace Helbig and Jack
ferry at Mitchell Davis and we are doing
another episode of not too deep Rance we
got the gang back together yeah yeah
we're ranting about um we were unsure
about this and then we are very a
pathetically agreed to rant about summer
summer don't even get me started on
summer seriously okay so what are we
ranting about with summer how hot it is
Oh God can you believe this heat waiter
we really just jumping into like that no
interest no nothing I ensured you
enjoyed you as lockers McGee welcome my
friend that's barely hanging on and then
my other friend producer extraordinaire
not too deep Jack very well I think we
should reconnect because it's been a
while
oh yes Mitchell hasn't been on the
podcast since it's been about a week
Valentine's Day right oh yeah was
fountains there last that was our last
life Mitchell and Jack yeah it's Java
ganja yeah
ganja extravagant yeah yeah extravagance
Mitchell's Friday night is what you say
right at 4.20 4.20 looks like a drug
dealer right now it's me like European
soccer not even hoodie jacket and some
dollar but no hundred-dollar bills all
over these parts grace shot a collab
video with Ricky Dillon yeah and she got
covered in pickle juice almond milk and
Diet Sprite Oh diet cherry 7up oh sorry
yeah apologies yeah you know so classic
YouTube videos the classic so she didn't
have a change of clothes so this is what
she found is this closet yes this is you
know just the standard ensembles that
live in our office wardrobe but I gotta
say you make it work thank you I think
I'm also wearing Jax belt because these
pants didn't fit and I tried to use gaff
tape to hold them up hey DIY Mason style
check out the mug you actually take
advantage of the beach in the summertime
yes all the time I mean once I try to go
I try to visit the beach once a week do
you guys go together sometimes sometimes
you guys often he'll just come over and
take my beach chairs letting me know yes
what like a Jack and Mitchell day at the
beach looks like we will be here can I
set it up for you is what it is first
off let's all just imagine me with no
shirt short shorts just a rockin bod I
got like a 12-pack Jack on the other
hand is just imagine you know his beard
imagine that all over his body
we're walking together we both have what
looks loading hands yes just pinky -
pinky - pinky - pink life you guys
always do they always walk into this
office pink you - pink and we got we got
our beach chairs on our backs cuz they
convert into backpacks it's kind of cool
Jack don't ruin my story so which beach
to go - can we not wear this is miss my
local beach I don't want to give the spa
blow it up
is it a popular spot no not at all oh
okay it's not because it's so close to
the airport which I think scares people
away yeah cuz all the [ __ ] from the
planes fall on my face but I don't mind
it I kind of like it do you have
something that you hate about summer
Mitchell sunburns sunburns yeah just uh
you have a sensitive summer body I do
have a sensitive summer body well you
have a sensitive outdoor body I chose a
sensitive body I'd say all you do have
very soft hands I would yeah I have none
of the pinkie touching right it wasn't
that I forget what it was if you were
like shaking my don't make this weird
thing I forget what it was and then I
remember being like God your hands are
feuless hands no feet no no feel the
yeah these are very really clammy and
soft yeah they'll have some editing
hands in the hands of a man who's never
worked a day in his life and that's the
side of a computer oh yeah right he
works very hard indoors
no barely I mean let's be honest guys
but they are very soft give me a call
five five five Mitchell soft hands calm
you've had some sensitivity around the
Sun and your body I heard in the past
that you got a rash because your body
didn't get enough Sun look give us a
sparknotes version of your history with
the Sun and your skin and where you are
today I had a red splotch on my back I
went to the doctor said what it was in
so many words she said boy you need to
get more Sun in your life and I said I'm
so sorry that I even came here because
I'm so embarrassed because you just said
I have indoor kid disease to my face and
she was right and I started going
outside and it's gone so next sex what's
already talking my next but that's a
great story it's a story of triumph a
story of I did it yeah I went outside
without a shirt on an inspiration to
hundreds of kids I think I might do like
a book of memoirs just about that just
that one moment in my life it'll hold
the whole books about this one day that
I left without a shirt on indoor kid
disease yeah indoor kid disease oh
that's amazing
I love it the story of Liv Laval is that
that makes a lot of sense yeah yeah I
would buy that book oh god Jack would it
happen
hang on so then I was listening so that
I'm like alright well that didn't work
so then I started to me the opposite
direction yeah I'm swimming really
really really hard hard as you can yeah
you got to you I pop my head up where
are you and I'm even further no you're
not
tell me or not Jack are you okay I'm
serious it's really high I believe you
dude I'm listening
it sounds like you're making fun no I'm
I'm just in it